[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHIVA SHIVAKUMAR:
Fundamentally, more people
are moving to cities
and whether this
is Sau Paolo, or Beijing,
or Mumbai, or Singapore.
And it's actually
putting a lot of pressure
on the underlying
systems in cities,
so the roads, the public
transit-- buses and trains--
and more importantly,
the commuters who
are commuting every single day.
So we're looking at
how to use technology.
So a combination
of spatial insights
can also behavioral incentive
to change this ongoing problem--
this growing problem.
BALAJI PRABHAKAR: I think
the first moment was just
noticing that cities deal with
congestion by regulating road
or transport network
use, and they do this
by sort of increasing charges.
This is the economic
way of driving up
demand when there's
an excess of it.
And then you soon realize
that this solution is not
easy to sell.
Commuters don't like to be
paying for something that they
didn't have to do before.
And then the "aha moment" was
could we incentivize commuters?
Could they be given monetary
incentives or social incentives
for nudging their behaviors?
And so, that's for
example, an "aha moment."
SHIVA SHIVAKUMAR:
Fundamentally, when
you're looking at
analog data, there's
a whole bunch of
new things that need
to be solved in that context.
So on the data processing
side, in terms of scale,
in terms of the new algorithms
that actually can help
us understand that
data a lot better.
And also the
visualization systems
that actually can help us
get much more deeper insights
into both the spatial side,
as well as the data side.
So essentially
what we're doing is
we're building our new systems
that are much higher scale
and dealing with this
new class of data,
and also visualizing
that to give
fundamental insights to people.
So what we are
looking for are people
who have a shared passion of
making urban living better,
and also building out
these new systems that
have not been done before.